the reason that you haven't been able to
trust your team is because your team
sucks and it's reasonable that you don't
trust them because they are not good and
so you hear the people say oh you got to
delegate and you're like when I delegate
these guys are idiots and the person
whose fault that is is yours because you
hired idiots you did not train idiots
and you continue to employ ideas for
real the concept of trusting people and
delegating Authority is absolutely the
right strategy but the implementation is
where people fall short is because they
can't judge people well and they're also
not the type of people that can attract
that level of talent